hey
this holiday season one of the biggest
arrivals on the Xbox one is the return
of Master Chief in halo 5 Guardians now
the Halo fans on your list may have been
riding with the UNSC since late October
but that doesn't mean they don't want
some slick halo gifts this season that's
why gamespot has teamed up with Duracell
to power your seasonal shopping with the
best gift ideas to satisfy all the
Spartans in your squad first things
first you need to get yourself a needler
did I say yourself I meant your cousin
or your sister whoever you're pretending
to buy this for and then keeping it for
yourself this blaster from boom co comes
with 8 darts to load in the front and 8
darts for reloading up top and also
looking super cool it comes with targets
that you can set up and shoot but
honestly it's fun to shoot no matter
what you're aiming at and boom Co makes
a few other halo theme blasters as well
in case you want to start a full-on
firefight which I think we both know you
do if you prefer your play to be a
little less projectile then let's talk
action figures specifically this
McFarlane creation one of the toughest
Spartans to ride alongside lock in team
Osiris Holly Tanaka she survived the
glassing of her planet learned to speak
Sangheili and mastered computer systems
both alien and human she's one of the
toughest Spartans in the bunch but if
you like you can get a bunch of other
Spartans including Master Chief and lock
now it's just a matter of getting them
to play nice together maybe a tea party
alright now that we've got playtime
covered let's talk about actual play as
in playing the game there are a few
really cool limited edition xbox one
controllers from halo 5 Guardians and
this one here is a Spartan Locke edition
it's got some cool grey patterning on
the background as well as that blue from
locks visor that really pops on the
d-pad there's also a Master Chief
addition that has a green background
with a gold d-pad pack one of these
beauties with a pair of long-lasting
Duracell quantum double-a batteries and
the only conflict is going to be
deciding which one you use when you sit
down to play let's round it out with
some options for living the halo life
when you venture outside in the world if
your world happens to be chilly this
time of year then consider this UNSC
branded tube scarf it may not be exactly
the high n tight collar fashion of the
Spartans themselves well that's probably
for the best this accessory is made by
muster brand and when it comes to making
cool video
in clothing that doesn't necessarily
scream video games they've got some
pretty cool stuff on offer I think I'm
going to keep this scarf on for a little
bit you never know when you're gonna run
across a rogue covenant patrol see what
I mean hope you enjoyed our halo gift
ideas for the holidays folks now if
you'll excuse me I have some dark
fuelled revenge to carry out
you